hello film courage my name is tangerine
Leila yes that's my real name
I had hippie parents I found out about
this film courage contest from my friend
she encouraged me to check it out and so
I watched the video of Josiah black the
comic actor from Vancouver where I was
born and I live in Ontario now and so
he's a comic actor and his video was
about the performing support system and
I grew up a child actor I was a member
of actress and I grew up with hippie
parents and creative genius' artistic
family only child so you know I was the
gelateria girl I was in all kinds of fun
wonderful theater stuff and and that
became my world and I did a lot of it
alone and my family would say okay here
are some buds money and you know go to
your audition and see if you make it
back alive because it was the streets of
Toronto so usually I I made it back
alive sometimes I didn't but when I did
everything was fine and I never really
had a support system it was more of just
you know this was where you got to go
this is what you got to do and you know
now I'm 45 years young and I'm raising
my youngest son he's 11 he's amazing
his name's max two x's and that he is
more funny than me and my parents put
together which offends me at times and
but he's brilliant and we have a banter
and he's my support system and I even
though he's 11 going on 83 and has his
curmudgeon moments he he feeds my fire
to be that stay-at-home comedian and I'm
at
actually what I call a home comic so um
people say you know what do you do and I
say I'm a stay-at-home comedian
full-time mother with the part-time
headache and you know my kid is my
audience and I always wanted to get out
there and just do the stand-up and I'm
like well I can't take an
eleven-year-old - yeah after a bar cuz
it just don't look right and you know
what am I gonna do so I just stayed home
and was funny to myself and you know
like my fake plants and my kid so you
know now is getting older and I'm
thinking you know I want to get out
there and I want to go back into you
know the life of the after the artists
and and have fun and you know where do I
get that support system from so um
really good friend of mine told me you
know check this site out and you know
see see if anything picks your interest
and then we started talking and because
she mentioned this contest she said
she's been my support system and that
just made me like wow really what you're
gonna you're going to be there for me
just little things you know to help me
have the courage to go out and be the
stand-up comedian and uh you know when
my son is the beach I would love for him
to tag along because he's just in all
made for this and he inspires me but
when I watched Josiah Black's video it
really made me realize that I have been
hiding and now that I know I have a
support system it's encouraging me to
get out there and just live my dream and
I no longer have to be forced to be a
stay at home comedian I can actually go
out there so you know with that
also to ask you questions what was going
on in your life at that time when I
watch the video um specifically at the
time I was watching your video I think I
was combing out one of my wigs so um
that's probably what was going on
I do have bad short-term memory but uh
if I remember correctly that that's what
was going on in my life how do they find
the video like how did I find the video
look like a good Cabernet it was a
little tart and a little smoke it or how
did actually find the video um my friend
told me about it and then I watched a
video more than once yes four and a half
times and what key lesson did I take
away from the video you know like I said
just on a support system just knowing
that's a good idea
I'm just gonna get a support system my
kid and my friend because I try to do it
alone and like when you go in the
bathroom you wanna do that alone well
when you want to do stand-up comedy it
should do it alone you don't have to
write it at least try so I'm going to
give it a shot a legend and all that
turns out um how do you implement that
lesson into your life like I think I
said it but again I have a short-term
memory so I don't remember what happened
as a result what was the question
Oh any other impact um yeah just you
know what I I'm happy to be staying home
um but I got to get out there and I got
a live my dream my dollies try till is
my dream you know even if I'm in a back
alley of the comedy club talking as a
homeless guy for at least as an audience
of one so um what is your dream um where
do you see it taking you
at least a block away from my home could
you be nice to get out do something um
you know I do have a calling it's just
been going to voicemail so my final
thoughts and then I want to share I do
really appreciate what film courage is
doing I think it's great and helps
people I really realized that I would
stop until I watched it and the video
really helped me go I think I'm going to
just you know grab life by the cojones
and go out there and try to make an
impact because if I can make anybody
else laughs ever than my son and my
friend is they're biased at least I hope
they are um then then it's worth it good
you know I I love to be funny even
wanted by myself and I really want to
meet Jim Carrey one day just because I'm
Canadian huge Canadians we have rubber
faces and we can do stuff and I love
doing impersonations and I was a class
clown I was the only female black clown
in the seven schools that I went to cuz
removed a lot what if we find to at
least start to trial in my dream Nexxus
been a great opportunity
um I really appreciate you taking the
time to check out my video is there
anything in my teeth that I miss not
good
okay so thank you Josiah black and you
really maybe want to get back out there
and uh take a chat because I know I have
a support system and I'm not going to
let that go to waste so
thanks again for watching and I hope to
see you in the back alley behind the
yaktrax one day bye